les gens se connaissent histoire de
mettre le feu sur le web eh ben je vais
vous montrer les mouvements qu'on va
faire ce matin comme ça une fois que je
balance le son ça percute et on n'est
pas là pour tricoter hockey l'équipe et
c'est comme ça tous les jours sur la
toile avec bon nombre de coaches
sportifs de martinique une adaptation
incontournable de leur activité mise en
pause forcée pour cause d'épidémie de
coronavirus les cours en direct sur les
réseaux sociaux ou les coachings en
visioconférence sont devenus la règle
pendant le confinement au dessus du
coude donc c'est simple il suffit
d'avoir un téléphone portable une
tablette un ordinateur et s'il en est
une application qui fait ça j'ai juste
un posé ma tablette je m'installe je
fais en sorte qu'on me voit correctement
ayant fait le coaching se déroule
exactement comme si j'étais en présence
de de mon client et pour les clients
confinés chez eux
cette initiative est vécue comme une
véritable bouffée d'air frais c'est
plutôt aussi intéressant de pouvoir
garder un lien social pour voir voir ses
postures aussi enregistrer les vidéos
s'améliorer ça demande beaucoup de
volonté une grande motivation parce
qu'on est quand même tout seul donc
c'est vrai qu'on peut décider de ne pas
allumer skate mais ça vaut le coup déjà
parce que ça nous permet de bouger
mettre le confinement à profit pour
revoir les bases pour bouger ou pour
s'initier à d'autres sports
puisque toutes sortes de disciplines se
retrouve du coup accessible gratuitement
à tous vanessa par exemple propose des
cours de fitness zumba danse en direct
tous les soirs pour tout le monde pas
seulement ses élèves une façon de
poursuivre son activité coûte que coûte
en tant qu'indépendante eux
je me retrouve à faire des cures un
style télétravail j'explique je propose
tous les soirs en direct sur ma page
instagram c'est quelque chose de
différent de ce que nous faisons ça avec
vanessa
mais c'est tout aussi intéressant alors
je viens dans notre organisme
franchement c'est une super bonne idée
parce que je vais vous avouer que avec
ce confinement la boue c'est vraiment ma
meilleure amie nantais box et crossfit
sont aussi accessibles à tous et les
courants mode télétravail donne parfois
lieu à des séquences cocasse
matuidi